today I'm going to show you how to get  started using EDB postgres Enterprise  database in Google Cloud launcher EDB  postgres Enterprise provides  comprehensive management integration and  Oracle compatibility and migration tools  as well as services and 24-7 global  support from the EDB postgres Enterprise  landing page on the cloud launcher site  click launch on compute engine this will  take you to the select or create a  project where you can make your  selection next you'll be taken to the  deployment configuration page where you  can customize your instance and choose a  name as own a machine-type a boot disk  image network access and additional  options like management dis networking  access and security options the defaults  are designed to work well so we'll  simply select deploy and you're ready to  go to get started with the EDB postgres  enterprise on cloud launcher click on  the link in the comments thanks for  watching